without going with my name
welcome back to some our Jim yeah
there's a guy waiting for me there
guy
anyone else is anyone else oh that's the
guy who thought he could whoa what
happened oh yeah I got raped in the last
one I remember now that's not good for
anyone
it's just not good in general you should
not forceful it's like someone got
damaged okay we can't go in there
what a badge over here open security
hatch I'm rich man a dead man too this
back came from son of a [ __ ] okay but
we are going in no we can't go there we
have to go here pity focus man
there's a ladder over here I remember
now and there's a bunch of Gary's on a
story son of a [ __ ] gave me everything
ICU circuits of his own stick I got
mashed potatoes I'm an idiot
[ __ ] what did you save them doc that's
not a good start
okay Plan B go back get the security a
sting
I want those I am maybe have a rich man
go here and scare you so much other than
why to see you I thought I'm gonna try
and get this thing stable shut up all
right hi how'd you like poker
Wow it is a nice Pokemon what the [ __ ]
not everyone I'm a freak don't want to
get raped by these
more than one head I think
stay down by the effort oh thank god
we're still uh why did we go over here
apparently no we don't we go over here
[ __ ] I remember all the basses shut down
you're not supposed to talk oh no this
is what I got a plan what no no don't
read either I'm allergic to [ __ ] man
Wow it hurt it blaze that's how are we
going in here what come take me down to
[ __ ] down
alpha lab secret - I'm doing pretty good
don't confident I feel like there will
be no words good stuff because I'm a
badass machine I didn't get - I missed a
couple of things
Oh No
oh no what I'm not clicking shut that
it's very good oh come oh come on your
TV ah stop what the you're not supposed
to fly come back here what yeah
ah
you can't hit me can't even hit yourself
why would he just weighs the meat like
that I don't understand it at all it's
bad for me
what the [ __ ] what the hell
we going down there don't we go to the
rod no toilet it's always bad news what
do you want [ __ ] up out let me kill the
toilet someone else is hiding in here
[ __ ] off alright we're good I thought
for one second
alright let's investigate all the
toilets shut up sweating it I'm not my
father
oh we're actually supposed to go okay
[Music]
please help me got to do everything I
need help I'm the one in hell need I
are they fapping out there
I sound bad what the [ __ ] he's getting
fat paper it's bad for your health okay
whoa what's that what do you know
enough is enough man okay stop anything
fun
what are you doing you were being eaten
ah crazy people in this game I'm just
gonna all right we're going down there I
don't want it
where did this come from back at back
what
I thought it was done badly one
[ __ ] that I'm not going I'm going here
armored car I lived we got something
Wow
look at that hahaha oh oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't I
can't
are they nice I think they're nice Russ
wait for my breath I'm running now I'm
running now Russ don't leave without me
okay mono as [ __ ] madam [ __ ] okay
stop
[Music]
give me a break in this game you don't
get dragged in this game
don't come here this is my house well
you know what I did a quick save so it's
fine [ __ ] dick because I am looking
for SAP I didn't see any store it isn't
secret weapon now what do you want
haha you got Jeremiah we got zero we got
zero we got zero we got well nothing we
have fire help - no that's
fantastic this if you're new to my place
this is pretty much how it is any game I
play anyway so what do you want is a
doing hey yeah
I can't hear me what are you doing your
truck this is not a Misha bro I'm right
here don't jump okay
sorry man can help you with what lights
are all out uh-huh I'll lead you through
here if you can get me off this base but
they have a flashlight you know I can't
protect you I don't have [ __ ] hand
grenades [ __ ] yeah let's go all right
this is [ __ ] amnesia electromagnetic
pulses have knocked out the electrical
systems Oh course yes that makes so much
done I am good knock out our lights okay
we don't really have any lights I have a
grenade you have lights
well I have flashy I'm not using light
canary
well we are Shawn this is kind of creepy
don't leave me Edward and you stay close
to me bro
well is that I don't know I had to stay
close hold me and and hold me
and I don't like this then I'm shot it
man I was not close I [ __ ] die but
they shot up a batch well I'm done with
your problem come on man why are you
laying around there because the blonic
that's awesome ah I'm at a time Russ
gotta end it yeah like a Barry's you
enjoyed that's gotta come Friday and
I'll see you next episode of whatever I
make no Jeremy I'm starting to find you
are grounded Brad